doch claus guths autobiografie ist nicht
chronologisch
sie beginnt mit dem schlüssel moment
seines lebens mit dem tod des vaters
im ersten band sterben verhandelt klaus
gott seine schwierige beziehung zu der
allmächtigen vaterfigur seine kindliche
angst aber auch seinen schmerz als
erwachsener als der einstige tyrann als
säufer in totaler verwahrlosung stirbt
meer gelangt zu denken dass es mir nicht
gelang zu denken wo er nicht denken
sollte dass ich nicht fühlte was ich
fühlen sollte vater ist tot dachte ich
das ist ein großes und wichtiges
ereignis
es sollte mich völlig ausfüllen aber das
tut es nicht denn hier stehe ich und
schaue den wasserkocher an und ärgere
mich weil das wasser noch nicht kocht
der übermächtige vater taucht auch in
den folgenden auf und überschattet klaus
kurz eigenes vater werden dass er ihnen
lieben in seiner ganzen ambivalenz
schildert
weil er mit seinen kindern keine zeit
mehr für das schreiben hat und sich nur
noch im hamsterrad der familiären
pflichten dreht gerät er in konflikt mit
gesellschaftlichen rollen vorstellungen
was mache ich eigentlich putzen waschen
essen kochen spülen mit den kindern auf
dem spielplatz träumen sie herein holen
und ausziehen
sie baten sie zu bett bringen es ist ein
kampf wenn das was mich während meines
gesamten lebens als erwachsener
angetrieben hat der ehrgeiz einmal etwas
einzigartiges zu schreiben in dieser
weise bedroht wird ist mein einziger
gedanke der wie eine ratte an mir nagt
mich aus dem staub zu machen
meisterhaft kombiniert klaus gott die
akribische nahaufnahme mit der
philosophischen reflexion immer wieder
konfrontiert er den leser mit großen
fragen wohin steuern wir im leben was
ist erinnerung was liebe was tot
in den letzten beiden bisher auf deutsch
erschienenen bänden spielen und leben
blickt klaus gott in seiner jugend
zurück spielen schildert seine kindheit
in der südnorwegischen natur eine zeit
der großen freiheit aber auch der
maßlosen ängste
leben behandelt sein jahr als blutjunger
aushilfslehrer in einem dorf am
polarkreis in dem knaus gott die
sexuelle nöte eines heranwachsenden
schildert aber auch keimende hoffnung
ich hatte die dunkelheit immer gemocht
wenn ich als kleiner junge allein war
hatte ich angst vor hier doch gemeinsam
mit anderen liebte ich sie und die
verwandlung der welt die sie mit sich
brachte als ich älter wurde gab es nur
wenige dinge die ich lieber macht als
nachts im bett zu sitzen
die dunkelheit und die stille enthielten
das versprechen auf etwas großes
mit entwaffnender ehrlichkeit betrachter
klaus gott sein leben
schonungslos sich selber und anderen
gegenüber
auf der suche nach absolute
authentizität bis an die schmerzgrenze
hier hat sich eine alles von der seele
geschrieben ohne rücksicht auf verluste